american-made is directed by Doug Liman
and stars Tom Cruise as Barry seal a
real-life pilot in the 1980s who's
recruited by the CIA to take pictures of
things they want to track and also ends
up being a drug runner for Pablo Escobar
at the same time now Lymon and Cruz's
the last collaboration turned out great
edge of tomorrow
yes it's called edge of tomorrow that's
when it's called okay I mean that's the
title of the movie it's called edge of
tomorrow that's what's called if the
words based on a true story weren't
shown at the beginning of this film you
wouldn't believe any of it it's that
insane and yet it happened Barry seal
had money in the CIA he had money in the
drug trade he had a successful family
life he had a business and too much cash
to do anything with their sequences
later in the film where they are trying
to find places to put cash because they
just have so much it's overflowing in
their house and this film takes sort of
a comical approach to this story while
also having sequences of real genuine
tension as well
Liman has chosen to make this film very
documentary s with his camera work a lot
of handhelds crash zooms a lot of
editing and that style is really good
for this type of film because it also
lends to the fact that this story is so
unbelievable but when viewed through
that lens as well as the guise of
knowing that it's true it really boosts
the believability and the credibility of
the story it also makes the production
feel more low-budget than it is and in
this case that's a really good thing
because you're watching events that are
told through a very specific I dug
Lyman's eye he uses at times of VHS
aesthetic with the opening studio logos
as well as the end credits and you get
to see some VHS footage of Barry Co
played by crews of course this is one of
the better roles that Cruz has had in a
few years because he's kind of an
antihero and those are usually my
favorite crews roles where you
understand his viewpoint kind of but you
know what he's doing is wrong but the
characters complete obliviousness
to just how bad and how low he's getting
is really funny and
film understands that and it takes
advantage of that comical side of this
character because whenever he gets
offered a new job and given a giant bag
filled with cash no matter who it is
whether it's Pablo Escobar or the US
government handing him this money he
just smiles and says cool that sounds
like fun
and digs a hole even deeper than he was
in before and it makes the character
quite compelling as well as the film as
for flaws the movie feels a little
lightweight at times the tone that Lyman
has chosen makes the events feel a
little inconsequential it's a very tense
time for the nation of the United States
and it's portrayed very funny and
light-hearted and entertaining and so at
times you just don't really feel that
invested in the characters because as I
said Barry she'll as a real-life person
clearly is very fascinating but the
movies portrayal of him is more of as I
said he viewed everything as this big
party or this adventure when he does
realize he's getting in over his head it
can create for some really compelling
character moments and I think what's so
fun about the film is the fact that this
character who should really be pulling
his hair out at what he's gotten himself
into and his family somehow views it as
fun and so it's fascinating but that can
have an effect on the overall tone of
the movie where you leave kind of
thinking like okay well that was
enjoyable but what did I really take
away from it there really is no giant
glaring flaw beyond that this is one of
the better Tom Cruise roles he's had in
a few years it's a very entertaining
movie I liked Doug Lyman's viewpoint of
this time in history and I'm gonna give
American made a B+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon as well as the
start of our fifth annual Halloween
special that's gonna be really special
this year instead of just doing one
video like we've done the past four
years we're gonna fill the entire month
of October with this Halloween special
various videos horror movies family
films I can't wait
it's gonna be a lot of fun guys thank
you very much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]